so this is me leave it all burn NBC news
calm and talk to you about content sites
to the best of my ability so the reason
why yeah the big reason for the switch
had to do many other things but we
originally moves from they SP done it
back-end to note so I could get into the
wise on that but you know it was mainly
for its organizational kind of like
workflow and just being able to eat
faster and make changes and and really
scaled down our us so so the first kind
of for range that was this preview site
launch which was just me covered like
this this is a bit outdated just reach
out but this is a site right now so I
don't anyone else here a news junkie
so however believe it or not we actually
do have lots of traffic so I'll prove to
you right now there are people using
this that you know I think that's
admissible handed room but we're working
on that very now there's twenty seven
thousand you know real time you do
something to say boils down to about 300
million pageviews per month so you know
we're we're serving up a lot of concepts
and on this home page we've got a
hundred and thirty some headlines on
this so we've got kind of a challenge
there and also things it's it's great
when an editorial can come to us and
like you know we can test out new ways
of changing this land okay so let's
start off this preview we actually
launched the new cover doesn't look dull
calm in July and we're now only trying
to move the rest of the site on for this
new static so the stack we're you know
just using some express magic excited go
with end of ours that js4 D is used in
the templates the reason for that is
that we really use a MVC framework that
was built on top of a client side of
this new framework that was built on top
of him
but maybe because that's kind of what
triggered this change for us so so
you've got we've got Express handle ours
we're using kind of like a custom-built
cap service when we need to say it is to
catch key and we're storing this cache
key that right it's kind of interesting
we came across using our data API our
music yeah we're basically just having
one server that caesarian hits this API
as much as possible and shove them in
the Redis it was it was a little bit of
a a little bit of disagreements on why
we should do it that way but it turns
out that being able to kind of like
separate our with like what are our
community service does was actually
allowed us to make changes so here's
like some of the models you know don't
give it too much but it's not a whole
lot some of the stuff I mentioned
Express handlebars Redis there's also
one new one and I mean Ralph cash which
is something that we built and this is
our basic Express setup like I said
Ralph cash there's a peak piece of that
I'll kind of get into that why but and
also expressed just one
here pseudo good so this is a rat cache
this is actually a simplified version of
that but so when each request comes in
for the state of cover or a a section
like a slash tech on the same is what
we're doing is just wrapping the
expresses response that's in right so on
the when the request comes in we store
that and cache and serve it whenever
it's available right so if you go to
check out the Indian modular out pageant
it has much more to which kind of helps
around kind of like the thundering
herd's of wound of Gotland you know
thousand requests come in at once we
don't actually serve that best thousand
time into it the first time and then
initially you know bash up all these
chains and then we turn that one
response so so literally we're only
hitting our reddit for every server you
know with that burning process we've got
our servers hitting when it's once every
15 seconds so do the math it's not even
like touching what
but the idea is that we can kind of get
sloppy and and do things and do crazy
things in our views that maybe it's kind
of frowned upon grow up I'll get more
into that so these are simple kind of
like how we're setting up our router I
guess the only interesting part here is
by using the little where you know
router you're reading you can kind of
separate out a lot of the logic from
let's say like right now we're working
on Elections so if you kind of separate
out that code nicely and create what
they call kind of like these sub acts
it's kind of a new feature within the
Express floor but of course the great
way of handling errors and here's an
example of cache service how that works
at this we've got a route with these
cache servers that basically it's and
you know next thing about this is that
we're abstracting out so we've got local
JSON files so when we're in development
we basically just say go get this decent
file locally and when we're in
production it's getting attached to the
Redis so it's really nice and that's
really the focus of what we're trying to
do we're trying to make you development
workflow easier for you know you don't
have a ton of JavaScript at all
irony but for our purpose on earth and
our web developers to be able to kind of
simplify things is great and yes to
mention the the Ralph cash here the
benefit obviously is that when it goes
to this route it's not it's not making
this cash service not get every time
it's only doing that when they catch
inspire so
once
absolutely and also the renderer you
know by reducing the regular countries
where the bottleneck was for us so and I
will kind of up on that here's some
pseudocode for how that has service kind
of works I sort of talked about that
home we're giving the cache key and not
you know do the right scale we also have
more code this kind of goes down you
know whether your production development
actually we're using the elastic cache
in Amazon so this would you actually
switch back and forth between memcache
the redness and it works very much the
same way just kind of go over we're just
you know rely on Amazon of course in
front of our nation with these servers
we have echo my so with things to go
down you know we're scenario content
yeah talk about reading our worker
process how that just basically turns
away and regi and updates all the taxi
service
so yeah you ended why handlebars you
know I sort of that you know handlebars
has a few unites has a lot of nice
features to it you know even for a
server side you know that helpers the
syntax is very familiar and how parts
would work like pretty much all of our
designer HTML CSS second developers they
knew how to use them
for your bus and
project so just a lot of sensitive it
works very well now so some of the cool
each you know handlebar suffers we've
had to add on and at the time I didn't
really find this up but actually this
symbol I should use a lot of these and
actually had no idea they're very
similar this even if T cool I think they
have something very similar but you know
something you would never do client side
you know handlebars these have this like
if people will help her through this you
know it's doing a lot of checking and
you know it's probably crossing that
line I'm just having too much logic in
your in your templates so this is
something that you know a lot of writers
Diane will stay away from doing that and
just make the change is kind of all on
your data model right well that's kind
of a pain because we've got a good guy
and we have to go in like negotiate that
contract in it but we have someone has
to incur that cost it's a lot easier for
us to just do that server side and but
that was probably a big game changer for
us
you know just say look as long as the
API returns this structure we can
manipulate and lunge that data is what
you want and and you know not have a
pounding at all and it just makes it
really simple - I was actually really
surprised it's kind of a this gif equal
I think is that right here so this is
that the actual humper you can check out
my slide
assemble project I
has fun of in the bars like helpers that
are meant for server-side so cool way to
use this you know the story we were
looking a lot of historians type in some
photo and you can say whether this is
partially it said you wouldn't do this
if this was client-side but just the
fact that can render stuff not have much
penalty on it and also this you know we
also do you like get people of multiple
types so we're passing in this kind of
like double play eliminated the list of
possible values to be JavaScript
developer to do stuff here's another one
we had a sort to tackle the responsible
image problem that we have so we have
this guy service that we need they're
just busy crack the image URL and it's
also just a server-side helper do things
like you know it ready for a listing is
populate these out these image URLs so
no the thing here is we're actually
lately still learning all the image URLs
so you can see that we have a data
original attribute and then after the
document complete his fire we can swap
out that
that is that's a big kind of performance
who's for our starter times so yeah so
why why do you know what content sites
why I do kind of all this stuff servers
I'm rendering you know it's basic comes
down to it's the right tool for the job
really you know this is actually a new
makeover food school slide I found about
it when not to use high side skirts and
it was kind of funny goes like wow so
not to give in history but give back if
ever we launched a site that was a
client-side framework and didn't work
out so well
it actually the framework was amazing
like what he was able to do December so
it was an awesome framer a lot of still
a lot of images was not
or a confidence and kind of the team
sort of fell into the that track and
with this awesome framework we didn't
like we can make this happen and pulled
it off we launched today in a way that
someone whose big reveal and then try to
look at a major fit and you know after
looking at things like a live page
that's and finally figuring out why we
so now science so so using the around
cash and also the Express you cash ever
got some so that six years is on my
local machine so I'm sort of taking out
all that Network latency stuff but you
know to lender that pretty large copper
you know these are some numbers you had
when we first my first started
only you know 12 requests per second
with you - all right so this is like a
family and of course you do Glen so
turning on the capacities of stuffs
expressing how you do this constantly so
they give us a little piece for that
much
so once the implemented you know around
captain 15 seconds we're gonna get over
5,000 sites per second so that was
pretty huge that you can probably get
away like you could still have a first
bite our pop inside with a pretty good
one like you know two milliseconds if in
the way we're standing on Akamai all the
students we could have got away with any
problem and with that they actually got
an application does but this is a really
cool kind of way experiment how really
fast
doing this stuff it's been not like a
major of it and it makes a lot of people
I started out with like 20 servers and
we hope that it can handle it and the
server's aren't doing any like are they
even running right and because they're
just serving up request link nobody's
business you know serving up cache hit
us once every 15 seconds so they want
like 30 for our 20 servers Boeing kind
of calmed me down after we launched I
think we're usually make four
sliding five or six out whenever you
needed but I mean they were happy first
ever kind of you know we were pushing
this on top slide and it was a lot of
back and forth and they were more than
you know they're more of a Microsoft
paper yep MSNBC sort of merged set the
way from Microsoft and so the transition
has been thought there's a lot of like
change going on and you see yourself but
this made everyone super happy and you
know I've heard this same kind of like
being like moving from Ruby to know
sixty servers on Heroku mounted like
forward in all this craziness I don't
think it's necessarily magical it's just
you build your apps here's like the huge
payoff so this is right after we
launched preview so we went from an
eight point eight second start under
time to a one point three seconds so has
a right now II and all the large news
sites we are the fact we went from being
like the slowest to fastest in a couple
months which is cool Guardian is kind of
elders like the one of
and they do a lot of progressive things
around down you know my performance and
it's a fast absorbing economy so they're
constantly kind of like getting better
but you know we're still working on a
lot of the challenges are around them
trying to negotiate everyone once if you
first
they're almost be loaded and having to
like battle with you know third party
ads that they don't need you to do other
than waiting and trying to prove it out
another piece if this was a Vienna just
push our Apple to Heroku this people let
me it took on the area I missed that I
mean you had a couple yes uses
environments now that anyone can just
create a branch and get pushes the her
Ophelia here's my change and you know
back and totally change how these people
think about I don't like building new
features and testing about getting
feedback across organizational yeah also
here's another one it's best timeline
you can see the difference seeing so I'm
stood there pretty lucky to networking
so we gotta go called snack art
Stacy just uh say this is pretty fun
solidus fill it out and there's someone
else really knows
it's very similar and he interested
the API is built so let's go by the next
part of our transition we're going to
start building our API that team is
looking at and I think let's go I would
love for them to move but still trying
to convince them but then we can't go
right now sorry there's question it's
still there see that
yeah well we have some missing family so
test Iran yeah like every semester that
we come on Mowgli but when we yeah so
will you eat some as well so when
we when we push something master or for
our future branches it also gets built
unfortunately we've got a handful of
tests that I make sure that none of our
templates are crashing now our stuff
with her a Super Bowl income is like if
we do or the investment will just be
testing like Express the receptacle so
we're just trying to leverage stuff
that's already
yes oh yeah front end the HTTP cache
that whole area is Jacqueline
then we've got everything on AWS it's
actually you know what I guess what I
said is servers which by the way to
suspect anyone who worked on their riot
or the nerd community suspend the nerd
is totally enabled us to I initially
pitched Jesse Ventura and so we've kind
of been in the middle and said
right
it does sure so good question you know
we don't have like 8 a.m. we are still
getting a lot of requests through the
yeah there are there are caching details
directly because we want your
frustration where you use where that
thing needs to be possible so can't just
server clusters kind of with officers
kind of a health you don't want like
spikes we don't want that she's calling
us bikes all day that scares people it's
kind of the reality like I think there's
someone in Provo right this is great but
you know when you have like kind of part
of the organization that's monitoring
servers looking is just very quiet
so everything mean he had some the
reality of sanity we do have some things
that are Leonard I said we're using
mustache I'm sorry the reason handle
arts now on certain things that are
updated like the local news section so
that's getting old for many of the
answer that lenders after the page loads
really just and the only reason for this
user than going to change their zip and
things like that but that's really
pretty much it
it's your site's content sites are not
like interactive zoo
well well know so if I'm going to our
cover I mean the cash is constantly
updating right so as those as that the
TTL on our cash fire it's getting the
content so there's a TTL on the webcast
itself it's really just a stopped you
know but
so the that render kind because of all
these helpers are using and kind of
building I mean you have have probably
50 60 80 parcels that we reasoning on
that cover to render all that is not
instant so we need something there to
kind of follow that and you know keep
serving on pages quickly without pegging
the process
are you going straight to the server
Lords their age a proxy or an actor
something sitting front
no it's right to those races are you
doing anything good load balancer oh
yeah so he'd be reasoning yeah this is
bit more on the outside right but
they're using the Amazon balancer across
there is a local app cache but in
development we're using just the static
files so yeah so its first populating
its constantly accessing me on every
request satellite access the local
memory cache and then that per process
so definitely processes personally no so
the thing that kind of shares in these
reps so after those individual caches
inspire which is short very short honor
like one second video actually we
haven't that's still rendered I mean
that is very much a separate API but the
video which has become our story pages
we haven't we're still linking the
processing by grain there's over yeah
but really the note the video is really
just a player right and then it's going
from the video from a CDN
yeah but the we have like some of the
video some out of memory
it's not even mine and we probably have
a long way to go before it becomes an
issue you know and if you with primary
site owners don't treat the Reta certain
things kind of have like this balancing
act
using local view memory fashion
refreshing ad with the right hash